give our next sir thank you thank you
so I'm thank you for inviting me to the
workshop and thank you for the amazing
weeks we've spent here at Simons
I teared the title is not the title of
the paper but I am presenting just a
paper but I thought it would sound a
little bit more attractive to computer
scientists but it is the joint paper
with Xiao foo and Maya wind which is
named structural estimation of a model
of school choices and so on so it's
gonna be a very specific topic but
hopefully some of the ideas there can be
extra power both to ideas in computer
science about what the content of the
data maybe is and how to back it out ok
so so it's gonna be a talk very much on
school choice but again I think some of
the components may be useful for other
ok
so in many cities worldwide and there's
um there's school choice implemented
okay and more so it's being centralized
more and more as economists actually
come in okay but the the main problem we
have is that even when you allow for
people to choose school capacity is
fixed and so not everybody's gonna be
able to get the school they want and so
you sort of have to decide how you're
gonna decide who gets to go into what
school so what governments usually do is
they ask families to not only give them
the first choice but sort of hand in
rank ordered list and then using those
lists they try to allocate families to
different schools to satisfy those
preferences as well as possible okay but
depending on what then the government
does with this list and this is where
the field of school choice is initiated
depending on what the centralized system
does with this list families will not
have an
sent us to tell you what they really
want okay so the list to be submitted is
gonna depend it to a large extent to
what the central government is doing
with this list okay so a particular
example which was what started this
literature was the so-called busting
mechanism because it was the mechanism
that was used in Boston but it's a
mechanism that is used worldwide and
it's now also called the immediate
acceptance algorithm and it works as
follows so you have all this rank orders
list that you've been submitted and you
put everybody in their first choice but
if there's more applicants than seeds in
that school you basically rank the
applicants according to some priorities
that the government sets so those who
live in the neighborhood go first or
those who have a sibling go first or
those who come from particular poor
backgrounds go first or whatever okay so
you basically there's a set of points
that you get for different
characteristics that you may have that
determine a rank and those are used to
resolve over demands okay so the first
50 people are accepted in the school
that has capacity 50 and then what's
particular about this mechanism is that
in every round the assignment is final
so if your school is over demanded it's
filled up and the school is taken out of
the system okay so in the in the
subsequent rounds you the school that
you rank sex so if you've been rejected
from your school you may be assigned to
your second school but the set of
schools that are available at that round
it's just much smaller and you keep
going like that until everybody gets a
seat okay
but of course under this if this is
what's gonna be done with your list
you're not necessarily gonna want to
tell the truth okay so in particular
you're not gonna want to reveal that you
like a school that is very hard to get
okay because maybe you live in an 8 so
maybe you're in a city with neighborhood
priority and then you really like
meaning
you have priority for your school you
like that the school in your
neighborhood but maybe you like another
school in the next by neighborhood
better but the chances of you getting
bad because you don't have priority are
very small so me you just exclude that
school and just report that you want to
stay in your neighborhood school ok so
this was this was the main reason why in
Boston they took away this mechanism ok
but if you think about it what is the
problem with this mechanism why is it
wrong for people not you know why is
truth-telling important ok so one is
well it's painful to have to strategize
ok it would be nice if you could just
tell the truth and that's it right
second is you may exclude schools that
you shouldn't have exposed ok and that's
you know more efficiency may be inequity
depending on who's excluding what and
for what reasons but there's a paper by
Morales and another by Abdul Qadeer Lu
Chen Yasuda that showed that actually if
if there is a lot of congestion and
meaning in meaning that basically
preferences are very very similar across
schools it's just so people basically
have the same ranks and the only
difference is in the intensity with
which people feel for those schools then
this mechanism is not so bad because
who's gonna dare to apply for the best
school those who value it relatively
more right so this mechanism which to
some kind of self selection in terms of
intensity which may be good ok but this
is if the rank order was the same for
everybody and if there was no priorities
for anything else so it was just a
lottery determining who's getting you
know when I'm deciding whether I should
apply for the first my first best if
everybody has the same chances who's
gonna be the one that applies is really
just those who have higher intensities
but this is not gonna be the case if
there's neighborhood priorities ok if
there's neighbourhood priorities then I
just have you know even if I like the
other school and more
and other people because I don't have
priority for that's who I may not apply
for it and actually what we show in this
paper is that if there's neighborhood
priorities and if there's some schools
that are sufficiently bad this whole
game turns out more into a game of
making sure you don't get into the bad
school and so the safe option turns out
to be just to apply for a neighborhood
school okay so basically people will not
reveal their intensity is about anything
but they will just play it super safe
and just apply for a neighborhood school
okay and this is something that we can
check that we check in this other paper
empirically by showing that in the city
of Barcelona where by the way it's not
like the system is super segregated so
it's not like the presence of bad
schools is particularly apparent so if
the results hold here I would think that
in Chicago they should be more relevant
but in Barcelona we do see that most of
the families just apply for neighborhood
and we can identify that it is because
of neighborhood and not because of
preferences because there was a change
in the neighborhood design and we see
that people systematically change where
they apply for okay so in principle
there's all this you know all these
different things if we just have the
theory and our small little empirical
exercise in Barcelona you you know
Boston may be bad because of these
reasons Boston may be in a bad because
of these other reasons may be good or
maybe that I don't know okay there's
another factor that is important is what
happens so that has to do with this is
what happens when there's private
schools okay so we basically I told you
that at the end who's gonna be applying
for if everybody more or less agrees
about the preferences for schools then
who dares to apply for it becomes a
choice of is the risky choice at the end
right who dares to apply for the best
school versus incurring in the risk and
going in the leftover schools after the
first round which most most of the times
are much worse schools okay if you have
a private school outside option then
that changes the game for those people
to you can play more aggressively and
you're more likely to get into the best
public schools in the system
okay so there's a private-school effect
and there's another effect which is if
you come from a very poor neighborhood
you also have very little to lose okay
so you can also pay very risky okay so
you have sort of for the most part
people will be playing it safe and then
with the both extremes those who have a
private school or those who have nothing
to lose because their neighborhood
school is very bad they will actually be
the only ones who can take a high risk
and probably be successful because
nobody else is taking the risk of
applying for the very good schools in
the city okay so this is all theory
right what are the alternatives the
alternative that was implemented in
Boston was the Gaels chaplain I don't
need to explain this to this audience I
think right so the only the main
difference is that the assignment is not
final in every round so you can dare to
take risks because that doesn't harm
your chances of getting into any of the
schools I mean in any subsequent rounds
and there's also top trading cycles
which basically randomly assigns so our
interpretation for the particular case
of school choice is that you randomly
you start off by randomly assigning
people to one of their neighborhood
schools and then using the lists that
families have submitted you create these
cycles of mutually beneficial trades
okay so you can create this so you
there's this basically systematic
procedure of check checking for all
possible cycles of trades to make sure
that there's basically no efficiency to
begin okay so Gil sharply it's stable
but it's not efficient operating cycles
is efficient but it's not stable in the
same paper as before we show that under
Gil Shapley if there's neighborhood
priorities so if basically the city is
planned out in a way that basically
everybody has a neighborhood school and
they have priority for that neighborhood
school if there is a bad school in the
system or it doesn't have to be very bad
it's just that everybody
agrees on what the worst schools are
okay
so basically there's a very strong
correlation at the bottom and everywhere
else you can have all kinds of
preferences the final assignment will be
that people will go into the
neighborhood school even though they
will tell the truth they will all say
they may not like their neighborhood
school at all
okay but they slightly like liked it
better than the bad school and that will
basically leave them all to be assigned
to the neighborhood school okay so in
terms of getting people to move out of
their neighborhood it seems like both
guilds happily and Boston are doing a
poor job if there's bad schools or and
if there's neighborhood priorities yes
okay so which one of the two should we
apply in this in this particular case of
Barcelona shall we move to the Gaels
Shapley in the city of Boston shall we
move from Boston to guillotine anywhere
in the world shall we move to one place
or to the other
well there's neighborhood priorities
which is the case in many of the cities
you should think about it if you think
there's some vet schools in the system
okay I presented this in Finland and
somebody said I don't understand what do
you mean by bad schools and I see and I
thought it was a joke but the person was
like no no seriously I mean that if the
government sees that there's a school
that systematically nobody likes it
should be doing something about it I
said yeah yeah this is yeah I appreciate
your point I will move this comment to
the administration worldwide but
effectively this this has a huge impact
okay and I if if you guys don't mind
given the audience here I would like to
briefly explain you the result here
because it's a very intuitive okay what
did why this happens okay and it will
also help you understand some of the
empirical results we get so engage
episode suppose to make it very simple
that there's basically three
neighborhoods okay so you and I are from
the good neighborhoods and all of you
are from the bad neighborhood okay
so you would like any of our schools I
like her school because I like arts
okay and she lives in the arts
neighborhood and she likes computer
science and in my neighborhood that's
what they do okay so she would like my
school than hers and then the bad
schools and I would like hers than mine
and then yours
okay so we're all gonna be truthful here
okay so in the first round she applies
for mine I apply for yours and you
haven't half apply for ours
well I get her seat well I don't have
priority for her neighborhood for for
her school so whether I get it or not is
gonna be a random draw okay so I have to
bid I get in higher number than all of
you okay but not only this I also have
to gain so I also so she I have to gain
her seat and she also has to gain mine
okay because if not she's gonna claim
back her seat and kick me out so the
chances that we're both gonna be able to
get a nice enough flat lottery number it
just becomes small very fast so it's not
doesn't have to be a super large market
okay as n gets large the probability of
this happening is very small okay so
there we have the result there story
because we have large market and then
everything is very nice but just it all
oh no I am okay so okay so Gill chapli
is gonna even though families are very
truthful it all sounds beautiful the
final assignment if there's one school
and I can tell you that in both of the
cities it is the case the bottom of the
ranks look very much the same the top do
not but the bottom is do this is gonna
be an issue okay so which mechanism
should we use for different cities in
the world this is an empirical question
it really depends on the scenario that
you have in your school district okay if
there's bad schools and priorities you
should probably think about doing
something else but if you were
constrained to do that and I we just did
this very particular exercise what we
would do is try and so what we ideally
would want to do is get at preferences
so that we could do the counterfactual
of what the assignment would look like
if we move from Boston which is what we
have now to Gil Shapley okay but I
cannot look at what people have
submitted and think that that's the
preferences because I know that people
are lying okay so what I have to do is
back out the preferences how do I do
that
well I know well or we're gonna assume
that people know the game they're
playing okay and then what we see as
their list has to be the optimal
response given their preferences okay so
we're gonna assume they're playing
it's basically an individual choice
program so you know the probabilities of
you getting into each other schools and
from your choices we're gonna for your
preferences okay and then we're gonna
basically get at your household
preferences and we're gonna get at so
one of the concerns is some people may
not understand so we do have that
there's a probability that you're naive
versus view being sophisticated
unfortunately the only things we can
really pin down as you being completely
naive and I completely sophisticated or
completely naive we cannot identify
something in the middle okay
and what we're gonna do which is also
nice in the context of come you know
computer science is we're gonna estimate
the model using 2006 data but then we're
gonna do out a simple validation to see
whether the preferences predict a change
that occurred in 2007 so in 2007 the
city so before 2007 the city was divided
into disjoint sets so basically there's
you know if you lived in one of these
sets you had priority for all the
schools in that set but that also meant
that if you lived in the corner of
between two of these districts then
maybe you had some schools by but they
were from the other neighborhood and you
would not get priority for them so in
2007 they said well we're just gonna say
you have prayed for the priority for the
six closest course to you so that means
basically to us means we have a lot of
variation on the priorities that
families living in the Steven point in
the city face very different priority
before and after so we see whether
assuming preferences have not changed
which they shouldn't change from one
year to the other whether we can do
counterfactual and predict what happened
then
and I unfortunately will not show you
much of that but I can tell you it works
okay I'm gonna focus more on telling you
what can be learned from having done
that exercise okay Inc what was the
first brave person to tackle this
problem
and he wanted to do it a lot more
rigorously than we do so he was
basically wanting to solve the full game
we're gonna do like a very large
simplifying assumption which is we're
gonna assume that people think they're
small enough so that their actions is
not gonna are not gonna affect the other
actions of families in the city okay so
that's the main difference with them
alcohol and some money they develop a
different methodology than we do which
can be applied for a small number of
schools okay so I will
tell you in a second how we do it and
why the size to us is not really a
problem okay and then how long relaxes
some of the assumptions that we make
which also allows them to identify a
little bit less but anyways okay
so just very briefly about the system in
Barcelona so we have 96% of the schools
are run by the government half of them
are what we call semi private in the
sense that's a little bit like charter
schools they're financed they're public
but they're fine they're financed by
their managed privately okay so it's
public money given to private
institutions to provide the service of
providing education okay and it's
basically half of those so we have
ninety-six percent of the schools are in
this centralized procedure and there's
four percent that are purely private and
are outside of the system okay in the
case of Barcelona the assignment happens
when the kids are three so there's no
way of using anything but just you know
whether you have an older sibling in the
school or not whether you live in the
neighborhood of the of the school or not
other characteristics like whether you
have a disability whether you have a
large family whether single parents
single mom or Signet single dad and so
on and so forth so small things this the
points here are very small and then the
rest is basically a random draw okay
by the way questions
I've been talking and talking no
questions
so very briefly it's a very simple model
this is just modeling the individual
choice okay so just writing minimum
model so that we can describe the
individual choice
so there's de schools and they're
distributed across the city in two
different zones each school is endowed
with a location that belongs to a given
zone some observable characteristics
that I will I don't think this audience
is particularly interested in and also
this is something you're not interested
in I'm thinking it's just you know
whether things are observed to the
econometrician but not to the citizen or
citizen anyways and then the household
there's a set of characteristics that we
see so we merge the choice data with
census data so we know parents education
we know the family location so that we
can know all the set of choices you had
which priorities you had for each of
them there's a an addition kradic taste
that we don't observe and there's a type
distribution meaning I mean you have a
type okay but you'll see that when we go
and estimate it we're gonna have a
problem we're gonna estimate the
probability that you're okay and then
each house will also has a priority
score for each of the schools okay so
given the characteristics and given your
location you're basically assigned a
different from priority score for each
of the schools in the system
okay preferences is just a function of
your own characteristics of the
characteristics of the school the
distance from you to the school and then
somebody on idiosyncratic shock okay
then there's an outside option available
here we normalize the value of that tube
so the absurd options remember it's just
the private school in this case we
normalize the value of that to zero
which only means that the estimations
we're gonna get are going to be
normalized so that private schools are
zero but that in no way means that
everybody values private school in the
same way okay this is just a
normalization
then between application and enrollment
there's yeah that's also econometrics
things happen in six months you and you
submit the list at a different timing in
which you enroll so things may happen
and so some people leaves on the other
end so to fit that you need to add a
shock so that you can basically fit the
model to that okay yeah education yeah
some some some houses
right so that's what I said that it's
just a normalization so for people that
for whom the private school is a very
bad option public schools are gonna be a
very high value so it's all relative
this shock here just to just to justify
some changes so there's some people that
just got the school that they told us
they like and suddenly we don't see them
anymore what happened so you just lost
your job and you cannot
so that's it this is a random thing huh
so it's not structural this is not it's
just - if you see something you need to
you know what happens if somebody's not
doing what you expect them to do there
has to be some random shock explaining
that it cannot be systematic
so this is between the moment where you
apply and the moment in which you enroll
which is you apply in February and you
enroll in September so things may happen
you may be say you can you want to go to
this semi private school which actually
forces you to have some co-payment and
you cannot
yeah there are some people that change
in between
you're thinking of people we are you
thinking of somebody somatically I mean
this would be a problem if there's
people if this is systemic right you're
fitting a rolling tool so we do see
enrollment data so if you get something
that that you really liked and then you
move to another neighborhood and you get
another school that is close to there
and we don't understand what you're
doing it must be a shock okay so it's
really an excuse okay and it wouldn't be
okay if it was systematically correlated
with somebody something observable about
the individuals but it's not you know so
it's just something to help us fit
well why special to the outside ultimate
not each individually
it so this is the end it's a shock at
individual level so it wouldn't make a
difference right I'm basically allowing
the payoff between what you got and what
you end up enrolling with so it doesn't
matter whether it's one or the other so
it's equivalent are the private schools
in the mechanism no shouldn't that shop
be systemic meaning that I'm more likely
to leave towards a private school if I
get like my second option right so
that's we really want to capture that in
the preferences not here this is a shock
we should not be explaining that part
with a shock we should be explaining
that with preferences so what we're
gonna see is that there's this kids with
rich parents they apply for the best
school in the public system they don't
get it
they go to private and that I want to be
able to explain so I don't want it to be
a shock yeah
you're not happy I will not talk about
this shock anymore so maybe you know are
you sure we can talk about the shock
afterwards anyways okay so what we're
gonna also estimate as the type
distribution so we're not gonna be
saying you are naive and you are
sophisticated we're just gonna attribute
a probability that you are being naive
to you okay and why is that because we
want to relate it to observable so we
need to basically take sub groups of
people and attach a probability to them
that they're being naive or not and and
we're basically gonna allow that
probability to change depending on your
observables so it's basically is your
level of education and the zone in which
you live why because at a given point in
time in particular now in Barcelona
families that are more sophisticated are
probably already living in the
neighborhoods where there's the better
schools because they move there
precisely because they wanted to be
close to change according to them okay
so how are we gonna get at the
probabilities that consumers I mean
applicants are supposed to use to
produce the probability so we said the
consumers are basically taking
assignment probabilities into account
what is the information we are assuming
they know is the following one is the
round at which the school is gonna be
filled up okay and this is not very
sophisticated information because 44% of
the school's fill up in the first round
and 40% don't fill up at all so it's you
need to basically you can ask the school
are you full already or not when you go
and submit your application and so you
can basically learn all of that there
the second thing that is going to be
important for people to know is the the
priority score for which the last
applicant got in okay so it's it's so
this is the priority score so you
basically means that the school which
you are going to apply for you need to
know how many applicants are there there
are from the neighborhood
that have siblings in the school and so
on and so forth okay and then there's a
cut up of the lottery number which is
something you do not know exactly but
you can infer what its gonna be sort of
by saying okay so there's all these
people who are from the neighborhood
there's four people without the
neighborhood there's still three seats
but it's six of us applying so chances
are that fifty-fifty I get in or not
okay so these are the kinds of things
that we need people to be able to infer
okay and as I am saying now families
submit their application in the school
so this information about the first
choice they can get okay so it's not
crazy to think that families in
Barcelona I can't learn these
probabilities for the first round okay
and for the subsequent rounds basically
as we'll see in a second
basically all families get their first
choice and if not they're pretty much
out so they don't get any other schools
that they applied for so it's
all-or-nothing kind of thing so the
information that is relevant is the one
in the first round and that's true not
only Barcelona but in in all the
empirical exercises that is a common
feature that basically everybody gets
first choice because they're very good
at just anticipating where they should
apply it to okay so that's also not
relevant
maybe appearing here but basically this
means that at the point of your final
utility is gonna be either the school
that you get into or the shock if that's
large enough to make you change your
choice okay that's off meaning you're
gonna go to an outside option okay then
what happens if you don't get so there's
317 schools in Barcelona and the list is
only allowed to be of 10 choices which
is more than enough because everybody's
getting either their first choice or
basically not much but the way the
assignment works is if you don't get any
of the schools of the ten schools in the
list you get assigned to a leftover
school which is the school that is
closer to you that has a free seat okay
okay so here's the what is the
decision-making process for the naive
household it's very easy they just rank
truthfully okay so nothing there
what about sophisticated okay so
sophisticated what the literature had
done up until now was say well you're
gonna have to well hold them yes so how
did we so two structurally basically to
back out the preferences given the way
we've set the model the way that this
estimation techniques work is you throw
in some parameters for the utility
function and you compute what the
optimal list is out of those preferences
and if the optimal list looks like the
actual list that means that is our good
parameters and if they're not these are
not good parameters only you know you
look for new ones okay but if for every
set of parameters that you throw into
the computer into the utility function
you have to compute all the possible
permutations of lists that you could
have you know applied for and compute
which one is the best out of all of them
that's very complicated okay that means
you know if there's 317 schools and you
can rank 10 that means comparing lots of
permutations for every single set of
parameters that you want to do so people
systematically either look for
environments where there very few
schools so that the phone was easy or
sort of try to reduce you just say well
you're not gonna apply for every school
in the city I'm just gonna assume you
apply to a subset of them for some you
know okay so what we're gonna do here is
basically understand that the way that
one solve this problem that this is very
helpful having lived through this so is
that you don't solve this by doing
permutations you solve this by doing
backward induction okay so when you're
thinking of the templates tool to put in
you're thinking well if I'm been if I've
been rejected from with all the previous
schools you know what are my chances in
the 10th round of getting and you you
know I look at what's left at that point
and
keep moving backwards okay and you can
do that because each of the elements in
the list it is is relevant only in a
very particular time so although
everybody is allowed to say is forced to
submit that list at the same time the
point in which each of the schools
becomes relevant is a different one
okay so you try in the first round and
when you get to the second option in the
second option you ranked that means
you've been rejected from the first okay
so that gives you information okay so if
you applied for a school in your first
choice that was very easy to get in your
second option you better put something
that is even easier to get in the sense
of the probabilistic sense okay because
the random lottery the only thing you
need to update here really is the random
lottery right because everything else
the priorities for each of the schools
that's set and that's known at the
outset but the lottery is something that
you need to somehow keep track of and
that's the only thing that you need to
keep track of when you do that backward
induction you need to make sure that the
only way in which it's time T or at the
point in the list T the previous choices
are relevant is in your updating of what
your lottery number is likely to be okay
for the first school in my list because
as you said you know if I don't get into
the first round I don't get in and so
I'm much more likely to optimize the
first school and leave everything else
I know random so everything else at
random means you're gonna be assigned
like it doesn't matter at that point
right you're just gonna be assigned to
the right so you in that so then what
the mechanism will do if you do that is
you're gonna try out the first choice
and then if it doesn't work it's gonna
sign you the closest by school that has
a free seat which is probably what you
would want anyway right so it's all
rational it's all fine
you know that's a rational way of the
in this model so if you're backing out
you're assuming that a consumer is
either sort of optimizing the entire
list of ten schools or non optimizing
yeah but what I'm telling you is that
the particular so I agree that that's a
that's a restriction but the particular
example you're giving me that would be
in the rational case too
that's why you know you know what I mean
because just playing it you know playing
the first choice very well and then
everything else doesn't really matter
because if you don't get your first
choice you really the options you have
left are really you know just that
so it's either there's the 40 percent
that 44 percent that get filled up in
the first round and the others don't get
filled up at all so you might as well
just choose the one that's closer to you
because more or less so basically the
ones that are worth going far away for
or this forty percent and if not you
might as well to stay in the
neighborhood school how much how much
does your estimation rely on the schools
that you list after the first very very
very little because the big because what
is available in the second round is very
common for everybody because the schools
that are available there are basically
schools that are not filled up so
anybody has that backup so there's a
lottery for a good school or an out you
know what is the if you don't gain the
lottery what you're left with is more
that's the same for everybody and so
yeah okay
so the only thing that we have to be
careful about when we do the backward
induction is that we need to take into
account then in Barcelona we do have a
common lottery for all the schools so
there is updating on your probabilities
of being accepted in each of the rounds
through the updating of that lottery
number okay but if the numbers were IAD
in the sense that every school had a
different lottery number then you
wouldn't need to do that it would even
be easier to run the backward induction
okay so basically this means we can
solve this very fast okay
and that the number of schools is not
gonna be hopefully not gonna be a
problem anymore okay so then we're gonna
estimate the model parameters which are
basically the preferences the type what
determines the type distribution like
the probability that you're naive or not
and I agree that naive or not is a
limitation but I don't think that in the
particular case the distinction and
behavior really is that story between
one or the other because it's all in
this first choice so there isn't enough
richness and what we do in that game to
really identify anything else okay and
then we're gonna try and fit the lists
that are submitted and your roaming
decisions okay and then we estimate the
model okay so this is the data we have
how bad am i doing oh oh okay good then
I cannot I mean I don't need to tell you
this which you don't like anyway okay so
basically what I just told you right so
everybody gets their first choice and
the papers are always very happy they
always said everybody gets what they
want
okay which is something that I also you
know these algorithms that oh one of my
optimize the match rate I'm saying you
know Boston is great the match rate is
amazing everybody gets what they want so
this just to connect to maybe why this
is useful also for
recommender systems and so on but
anyways so let me this is what we get in
terms of types distribution as you see
many of them are okay which means they
behave in a way that you can rationalize
with the Preferences okay that doesn't
mean they understand the Boston
mechanism or other sir but they
understand when people tell them is
there something you really crazy about
no then just apply for at the
neighborhood school which is what you
should do and then people play according
to that okay and there's a slight
correlation with with education but it's
nothing you know really crazy so here's
the comparison so once I'm not gonna
showing you the parameters of the
estimation because I don't think they're
particularly useful but they're just
very normal things
so here's if we move from Boston to the
airplane in Barcelona this is what he
would happen to the utility of
individuals aggregate welfare will go
down and this is for this particular
subgroups notice that the ones that
would benefit less from the change is
low socioeconomics so this point about
Boston being such that it's all about
taking the risk and if you're a very
high so low socioeconomics you're
probably living in a neighborhood that
has a very bad school so you have very
little to lose so you can risk it and
because nobody else is risking it you
actually get in
because you have to decide it's a
lottery that you have to decide upon are
you willing to take the risk or not and
that whether you're willing to risk or
not depends on the concavity of the
Preferences how you react to the
probabilities so there's this school
that in terms of observable seems better
I'm willing to take the risk given the
probabilities and you do not so I must I
must have higher intensity than you do
but the shock is on the outside option
and it's the same the shock is exposed
to explain enrollment not to explain the
choice of the data are the choice of the
applicant in the application put another
way suppose they took all the poor
students in your novel and multiplied
their utilities by two that would affect
the welfare comparison but it doesn't
seem like it would affect behavior but I
can I would have to change the zero as
well so it's everything is normalized to
zero I cannot do that and I then I yeah
yeah so I have the yeah yeah so then I
also have distance I have money that you
have to spend for a certain school so
you can monetize so if you if the
question is if we can pin it down to
something that is observable the answer
is yes so we cannot just double it for a
certain group and and not for others
because there's a yeah
so I see right so I see somebody who's
poor meaning what the only thing that's
relevant is in this case is he lives in
a neighborhood with a very bad school so
the choice for him is this my school
which is very bad okay
and this other school that is outside of
the neighborhood which is very good okay
and there's this other person who lives
in my scene in Berhad okay and it's not
willing to take the risk
so the exes are the same everything is
the same one is wanting to take the risk
the other one is not the only reason why
you would want to do that is because of
intensity
yeah but I you we can talk yeah so this
is okay so I think one of the super
important components that this is part
of the theory that I was talking to
before is that we show there in that
theoretical paper that risk aversion
plays a crucial role in determining
where you want to apply to and so
basically there's a separating you know
there's a threshold equilibrium higher
types want to do one thing lower tides
want to do another thing although the
model we did in this way I can
definitely see why we're getting it edit
okay you're estimating cardinal
preferences here to make these
comparisons okay
across the entire list of schools or is
it yeah for each teacher well it's it's
the entire because we parent
parameterize it so we you can you know
we estimated for whatever choices you
know you're revealing to me something
about
got it
so then you could also ask how far off
this is from the optimal assignment
optimal being yes that you do to see or
something yeah so we do so you see that
we're gonna do TTC okay as well and TTC
is slightly better but it's not a crazy
better okay oh wait so I do want to
emphasize this so I don't think these
numbers are super extra for logo because
who knows what these numbers mean is
this a lot or not I don't know but then
who wins and who loses in terms of the
assignment being better or worse there's
just a lot more losers than winners so
yeah let me just go fast because I
basically have no time and I do want to
talk about this which is what is the
fraction of households that are assigned
to their neighborhood when their
favorite is not in the neighborhood
that's highest what feels happy and
lowest with TTC so Boston forces you to
apply to your neighborhood more often
okay but Gail's happily even the weather
allows you to tell the truth you're
assigned to your neighborhood more often
at last similar flavor if you wanted to
get out of your zone right basically the
best mechanism for you is TTC and the
worst
[Applause]
we already had a lot of questions let's
jump straight into yeah